it's not enough that you don't believe  you need all of us  to not believe with you  why don't you admit the truth  you just want to ensnare them in your  primitive superstition what i want is  for them to make their own choice that's  what god wants i have no idea how much  i'm going to enjoy failing you never who  are you really looking to fail  professor  me  or god  she hates me make it work  but don't tell her about the way back  sigmund freud says if you don't like a  person it's because they remind you of  something you don't like about yourself  what do you know about sigmund freud  more than you think sure just like you  know all that stuff about george  washington not really cutting down the  cherry tree  larger than you i'm number one  you're number two  i believe in equality as long as you get  left me i'm one  you may think that you're smarter but  i'm smarter than you i'm number one  points for bravery stiff  bye